an appointment with by PCP this morning regarding the thrombone pain I get in my
lungs, specifically by thighs when I walk. She recommended that I try the
medication Pletal, generic form, of Cylostresol, I'm not familiar with
that medication. That is traditionally used for intermittent clonication. I have
opened to give it a try because the pain has become crippling and I do not
have much mobility at all as a result. I thought I would run it by you first
see if there's any effects on circulation bringing more blood to the muscles if
it would not be safe to use or not with horrible positive breast cancer. I don't
know. I don't know. I would have to Google it and search for it as well. On the
homepage of the member site there's a link to Drugs.com and you can search for
any medication in there and get a list of what they have to legally list as
the side effects. Then you can do a Google search. There may be Facebook groups
of people that have intermittent clonication that were on the medication and they
might tell you different things personally what they have gone through. I don't
have any comments on that because I don't know so looking that up would be your
best bet. Sorry about your heat in your legs.